point lead up this six foot eleven given  the right Oh  lean to the crosswalk  hurry  [Applause]  crowd went around Westbrook hits  Westbrook with a quick release hits the  three he now has 17 gone by in the first  four years  [Applause]  I meant a min for thunder Bahat off the  driver he slipped the double-team for  Kirino hips remaining  [Applause]  bring challenging terrain Oh read  verbatim  we're offenses as they finals for three  [Applause]  out of work at the post Rosa lock it  down  what's book of the Spenny West market  [Applause]  to the basket the first time my school  fire Chloe  - voiceover oh so you're gonna snicker  at my defense  me okay well I'm the two-time MVP  you laugh at that see the code that  [Music]  yes over Thompson could lead us down to  four just uses at 611 frame to shoot  over play Thompson  [Applause]  yes